hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my kitchen today we're going to be
making something very festive for the
July 4th holiday we are going to learn
how to make hot dogs so sit back and
prepare yourself for this instructional
how-to video today we're going to be
using ballpark parks finest these
actually come in different flavors we
have slow cooked chili jalapeno cheddar
and signature season I'm basically gonna
trick my friends into thinking that I
know how to cool but if they're my
friends they already know I'm not good
at it next step we need to cook the meat
in something hmm oh my I have in here do
you think you could put meat in the
toaster people says this looks like a
pan I might be able to get behind how
many hot dogs can I cook in this do
whatever you want to do this would've
been so much easier with a grill all
right how do you work this thing
maybe you'll pull this pin we're gonna
take our dogs and we're gonna place them
gently into the pan let's so let's give
you a better better shot I mean I want
to get them confused because we've got a
dog down but I'm yelling timber the most
important step in grilling or fake
grilling is to not have to call 9-1-1
but if there is someone that you might
want to call ball park actually launched
a hotline that you guys can call in case
you want grilling tips so guess who I'm
gonna call tomorrow not 9-1-1 I'm gonna
call the one eight four four four Franks
that's a phone number that is the number
holy crap they're they're receiving a
call from me to Metro current status oh
my god that smells so good
if I mess this up of me so mad homie
wants to eat these so Wow this is
happening here I'm gonna get a plate
ready
I recommend square plates because
basically anything that you put on a
square plate automatically looks a lot
fancier when I'm cooking there's no
place I'd rather be to do so so Oh God
Oh what do I do I need something to flip
them so right now what I'm doing is I'm
flipping them I'm doing a slight rotate
to try to get them all real nice and
simmering when do I know if it's done or
not oh that's right I'm supposed to be
teaching you guys how to cook this well
guess what if you actually think you're
gonna learn something here today
the dogs are starting to smoke and
simmer a little I think that's a good
thing okay well guys there's this is it
there's like two sets I can't wait to
call the hotline Amaro I'm really cool
oh excuse me I need to start answering
phones because I've got some tips for
you all right I think we're not I think
we're done not fantastic obviously you
want to impress your friends with your
amazing plating of the dogs so we're
gonna put them on a plate Oh son nap you
look great I don't know which is which
so we're just gonna we're just gonna
give it a shot
oh my god this is definitely the
jalapeno cheddar what's this one also
jalapeno cheddar alright guys thanks so
much for watching I hope that you
learned something like how to make hot
dogs on a stove using a skillet if you
want to get some actual tips you can
call the ballpark Frank's hotline and
you can tweet them and you can text them
so it's basically like a best friend
that is there for you at all times
during business hours let me know what
you guys want to see me cook next every
guys have a fantastic holiday I love you
I will be sharing these with some
friends now by showing the friends I
mean my father